a massive child abuse scandal rocks the
Catholic Church again the Omarosa
fallout continues and we have some
interesting results from a Minnesota
election last night I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
oh we have so much fantastic material to
examine today so many issues to look at
and really delve into first let me
remind you we actually have a big event
tonight right here in Dallas we are in
Dallas that's why we are not in our home
studio and we have an event tonight it
is nearly sold out we just have a few
tickets left already sold something like
3,600 tickets I think there may be less
than a hundred tickets left for the
event tonight we have one tomorrow night
in Phoenix same deal rapidly running out
of tickets go check out daily wire.com
slash events or Ticketmaster or Live
Nation calm and you can buy the last of
those tickets and join a massive crowd
of fellow patriotic Americans so go
check that out right now also I'd like
to remind you that your energy is is
flagging it might not be flagging right
now because it depends what time you're
listening to this but if you it's the
afternoon you're looking around you're
going oh god I can't believe there's
another seven hours to this day because
it's actually only 10 o'clock in the
morning you're already dying well that's
why you actually need the Oh max
cognitive boost if drinking coffee or
energy drinks is not doing the trick for
you you need to try the Oh max cognitive
boost it's a game-changing solution that
fuels peak performance by boosting
memory focus energy and all-around clear
thinking you will indeed feel the
difference immediately and right now Oh
max is offering my listeners 70% off a
one-month supply of cognitive boost plus
free shipping and a 60-day money-back
guarantee so if doesn't work for you
you'd have nothing to lose go - Oh max
boost calm Shapiro today take advantage
of that incredible savings it's Oh max
oh ma X boost calm slash capiro for 70%
off a one-month supply
they've got dual action breakthrough
technology of two powerhouse ingredients
they call them alpha and omega which
makes perfect sense go check it out
right now
cognitive boost you can get it again at
Oh max boost calm slash Imperial today
to get 70% off a one-month supply plus
free shipping and a 60-day money-back
guarantees whoo you really have nothing
to lose Oh max boost calm slash a pair
of terms and conditions to apply go
check it out it's solid stuff folks
around the office have been using and I
can say their efficiency is up massively
from where it was just a few weeks ago I
mean they're just better at their job so
go check it out right now Oh max boost
comm slash Shapiro okay so and what is
truly a horrifying horrifying story
yesterday news broke of a grand jury
indictment that was unsealed it was a
state grand jury report on sexual abuse
in six Pennsylvania diocese including
Berg and Greensburg it represents about
three million Catholics it's only six
out of the nine diocese I believe in
Pennsylvania so this is a very small
sample size but here is what it found
it's an 884 page document two years in
the making
according to PBS local in CBS it shines
a light into the dark corners of these
diocese going back seven decades
exposing the Predators and the efforts
of their bishops to protect them today
the most comprehensive report on child
sexual abuse within the church ever
produced in our country was released
says Attorney General Josh Shapiro
Pennsylvanians can finally learn the
extent of sexual abuse in these diocese
and this is just the latest example of a
scandal rocking the Catholic Church this
is the biggest one in the United States
they say they're over three hundred
three hundred sexually abusing priests
members of the of the archdiocese
hierarchy who are involved in the sexual
abuse of minors that is larger than the
Boston scandal the maid spotlight about
that was 150 to 200 priests over the
course of the private of 50 years this
was something like 300 priests over the
course of the last 30 years there over
1,000 victims the report begins with a
statement we the members of this grand
jury need you to hear this we know some
of you have heard some of it before
there have been other reports about
child sexual abuse within the Catholic
Church never on this scale for many of
us those earlier stories happen
someplace else someplace away now we
know the truth it happened everywhere
the report cites 301 priests clergy and
lay teachers this is not comprehensive
they're probably more with credible
allegations against them they're 99 in
the Diocese of Pittsburgh alone of those
99 a group of four groomed and violently
sexually assaulted young boys according
to the Attorney General of the state of
Pennsylvania one boy was forced to stand
on a bed in a rectory strip naked and
pose as Christ on the cross for the
priests they took photos of their victim
so they added them to a collection of
child pornography which they produced
and shared on church grounds according
to Shapiro and according to the grand
jury report and then in something that
sounds like all of the worst conspiracy
theories you've heard about Pizza Gate
okay that this actually happened
according to the Attorney General in the
state of Pennsylvania to make it easier
to target their victims the priest gave
their favored boys gifts gold crosses to
wear as necklaces the crosses were
markings of which boys had been groomed
for abuse and therefore other priests
would know which boys to abuse according
to the report victims were brushed aside
in every part of the state by church
leaders who preferred to protect the
abuse
and their institution above all the main
thing was not to help children but to
avoid scandal priests were raping little
boys and girls the men of God who are
responsible for them did not only
nothing they hid it all diocese and
administrators including the bishops had
knowledge of this conduct and yet
priests were regularly placed in
ministry after the diocese was on notice
that a complaint of child sexual abuse
had been made misconduct enabled
offenders and endangered the welfare of
children and the stories are just
horrific I mean there there are certain
allegations that
honestly it's it's hard to even it's
hard to even report on some of these
allegations because it's so
heartbreaking and horrifying and evil in
some of the allegations were things like
a seven-year-old girl who was who's
forcibly sexually assaulted while she
was in the hospital recovering from a
tonsil surgery a boy a young boy who was
sexually molested by a priest and then
his mouth washed out with holy water so
that he would think that this was part
of a religious ritual it's it's just
it's just horrifying in every possible
way and of course there were people who
were basically whitewashing this for a
long time so Cardinal Wuerl who's active
in Pennsylvania obviously he was asked
about all this and he said he doesn't
think this is some sort of massive
crisis right now when you hear of abuse
when you hear of a case of abuse when
you hear they're talking about things
that happened decades ago for the most
part I don't think this is some math
massive crisis okay that was Cardinal
Donald Wuerl led the Washington
archdiocese he is accused by the grand
jury of helping to protect abusive
priests when he was Pittsburgh's bishops
he's disputed the allegations he says
that the report confirms he acted with
diligence with concern for the victims
there were notes that were sent to
particular priests who were known to
have molested children in which they
express sympathy for the priests saying
that the priests obviously were
undergoing something very tough they had
to live through since they were driven
to do these terrible awful things most
of the Pennsylvania victims were boys
girls were abused as well when one boy
was forced to say confession to a priest
who abused him the the grand jury
concluded a succession of Catholic
Bishops and this is Reuters and other
diocese and leezar
leaders tried to shield the church from
bad publicity and financial liability
they failed to report accused clergy to
police and sent abusive priests to
so-called treatment facilities which
laundered the priests and then permitted
hundreds of known offenders to return to
ministry and their accusations that
there are similar things happening all
around the world in in churches ranging
down to South America this is a serious
problem in the Catholic Church Matt
Walsh who is a Catholic himself has a
piece over at Daily wire.com today our
website talking about how there needs to
be a full-scale cleansing within the
church and it is simply too bad that
this has not been done before and it is
a stain on the church now the reason
that this is newsworthy is not only
because it's obviously newsworthy but
because of what it says about each and
every one of us now not everybody in the
world is going to be an abuser thank God
most people are going to oppose abusers
think this stuff is evil think this
stuff is horrible but we do have to ask
ourselves what are you willing to cover
for and this is true for any institution
to which you hold oil tea because let's
not make any mistake here people are
singling the Catholic Church out as
though the Catholic Church is an outlier
when it comes to the abuse of children
as of the Catholic Church is somehow
much much much worse than other
institutions when it comes to abuse of
children how many children have been
abused in public schools my guess is a
lot of children have been abused in
public schools they've been studies done
we're talking thousands of kids across
the country who have been abused in
public schools by adults in positions of
authority there have been problems
inside the Jewish community there have
been problems inside the Protestant
community there been problems inside
certainly inside Hollywood the treatment
of children as sex objects happens
all over the world in a variety of
institutions the question is not whether
there are evil human beings there
certainly are there are demonic human
beings out there as Walsh says who ought
to be punished to the severus extent of
the law and the only tragedy here is the
death penalty isn't available from Allah
station of children because you molest a
child there is no question that you
should be killed in the most egregious
possible way folks who oppose the death
penalty I understand where they are
coming from in terms of the efficacy of
the death penalty in the administration
of the death penalty it's hard not to
look at priests were molesting
seven-year-old girls while they lie in
hospital beds and think those people
shouldn't be put to death right I mean
these people have forfeited a right to
live but with all of that said the real
question is why does this stuff last so
long and it happens within every it
happens in football institutions right
Penn State football
it happens all over people feel more
loyalty to institutions than they do to
individuals unless they know the
individual this is just a it's a
screw-up
in the brain okay they're they're a
couple of instinctive things that we as
human beings have the function in our
brain that are in conflict with one
another one of them is that we have a
lot of sympathy for people we know the
second is we have very little sympathy
for people we don't know and the third
is that we have a lot of loyalty to our
in-group so social science suggests that
we are all members of in groups there
are certain groups with which we
identify and when those in groups are
threatened by out groups then we tend to
rally in support of the in-group because
we have to bat batten down the hatches
we have to ward off the threat and this
is true in pretty much every area of
life it's true politically it's true
religiously in many places in the world
it's true ethnicity the
all cost you must defend them no matter
what you have to defend them from the
predations of the outside world
and that's a natural thing to do because
human beings are at least half animal
right even if as a religious person
we're partially made of the dust of the
ground and were partially divine will
partially had God's breath put into us
in Genesis but we are still part animal
and the animal part of us feels safety
in defense of an institution we feel
like we need institutions to protect
ourselves and we're not wrong about that
when that comes into conflict with
nameless faceless individuals we don't
know we tend to push the faceless
nameless individuals off to the side and
this is why all these folks out there
who tend to portray evil people as
monsters or the people who cover for
evil people as monsters I think that
that's just a lack of perspective on
human nature I think the Bible actually
has a pretty good perspective on human
nature each of us has a war going on
inside of us between what we know is
good and what we know is right and what
we know is bad but also serves our
interests and the hard part of being a
human being is trying to determine when
the stuff that is bad that is motivating
us is actually bad because the easiest
thing to do is to back justify the
easiest thing to do is to say listen my
institution has to be protected so in
the Jewish community for example there
been similar allegations against certain
rabbis and you will see the local
community defend the rabbi you'll see
the local community try and stigmatize
the victim right this is this has
happened in in certain cases in pretty
much every religious community I can
think of and that's because the idea is
well if you hand this rabbi over to the
secular courts for prosecution then what
you're really doing is bringing shame
upon the community it's gonna open us up
to allegations that were a closed
community in a bad community that is but
but here's the truth of it when people
do evil things it is your job as an
individual to call them out and the only
way you're going to be able to preserve
the truth of your institution is by
calling this sort of stuff out defense
of an institution when that institution
sins is a quick way to destroy the
credibility of the institution I can
tell you that the Catholic Church's
failure to take on this issue in any
serious way for years and years and
years and years has driven millions of
people I'm sure away from the Catholic
Church because people look at churches
people look at synagogues they look at
places that are specially supposed to be
spiritual and they say if these people
are supposed to be better then what
exactly does worse look like defense of
your institution requires you to call
out your institution when your
institution does something wrong and
this has political ramifications as well
and I want to talk about that in just a
second but first let's talk about your
internet protection with all the recent
news about online security breaches it's
hard not to worry about where your data
goes this is true for me particularly
since I am the target of many people
online making an online purchase simply
accessing your email it could put
private information at risk you are
being tracked online by social media
sites marketing companies your mobile or
internet provider not only can they
record your browsing history but they
often sell it to other corporations who
would like to profit from that
information which is why I use
expressvpn expressvpn has easy-to-use
apps that run seamlessly in the
background of my computer phone and
tablet turning on expressvpn protection
takes
only one clique expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data when hiding your
public IP address protecting yourself
with expressvpn it cost less than seven
bucks a month expressvpn is rated the
number one VPN service by TechRadar it
comes with a 30-day money-back guarantee
so if you ever use public Wi-Fi and you
want to keep hackers and spies from
seeing that data expressvpn is the
solution if you don't want to hand over
your data to internet resellers go check
it out expressvpn protect your online
activity today and find out how you get
three months for free and expressvpn
comm /ban that's Express
exp ress VPN comm / pen for three months
free with one year package his Express
VPN comm / Ben to learn more ok so I
think all of this has some pretty
significant ramifications for politics
because we have political in groups -
it's not just religious in groups I mean
he'll will form in groups to defend our
football team will form in groups to
protect Jerry Sandusky will form in
groups to protect - anybody who
threatens our way of life and those in
groups can be very dangerous this is
particularly true in the realm of
politics because politics is an area
where we must be having discussions with
one another it's an area where we must
assume that the other side at least has
enough goodwill that they want to have a
conversation with us and yet what we see
in our politics today is that both sides
are willing to justify Jim virtually
anything virtually anything because we
feel that our in-group is threatened and
here's the thing
we're not wrong about our in-group being
threatened because you can have a
mutually reinforcing system in which
both sides begin to treat the out-group
even worse and remember every out group
is somebody else's in-group you begin
treating everybody else's out group wars
so that out group treats you worse and
then you treat them worse and this is
how you spiral down into anarchy and
chaos if you are a person who looks at
your institution you say my political
institution my Republican Party must be
defended at all costs and that mean if
that means defending some vile behavior
I'll defend vile behavior because that's
what fighting looks like if that's
something you're doing maybe you ought
to examine whether that is actually
appropriate or whether it's even
necessary and if you're on the left and
you're defending an Tifa and you're
saying that an Tifa is necessary because
my in-group is threatened these evil
right-wing Nazis they're there they're
attacking my in-group so I will defend
an Tifa understand that you are
contributing to the moral decay of your
own side you have two choices when it
comes to your own institution
your institution conflicts with morality
choice number one is to help cleanse
that institution keep that institution
moral while at the same time fighting
off the people who had attacked that
institution for its actual morality
there's a difference between people
attacking your institution for moral
reasons and people attacking your
institution for immoral reasons right
people who are attacking the Catholic
Church handling of child abuse they're
doing so for moral reasons people who
are attacking the Catholic Church
without recognizing that institutional
failures occur at institutions at
virtually every level around the globe
right those are people who are doing so
for immoral reasons so motive does
matter here when we begin to question
each other's motives it gives us a
rationale for defending bad behavior on
our own side immoral behavior on our own
side and evil behavior on our own side
and this makes it more likely that our
politics breaks down it makes it more
likely that there's religious conflict
the minute we stopped trying to morally
critique ourselves in the same way we
critique the other side the minute that
we start seeing the threat to our
in-group as more pressing than the
morality of our in-group we destroy the
moral fabric upon which the in-group is
based in the first place our
institutions are killed from the inside
you wanna save your institution make
sure that you're as pure as you can be
and then make sure that you can fight
the other side that is attempting to
destroy you for things that are wrong
right if the other side is just
critiquing that's one thing if the other
side is trying to destroy you for things
that are just plainly immoral like
they're trying to destroy you for no
reason then that's when you fight back
but we have to choose when to fight back
so I want to talk about this in the
context of a Minnesota election and and
president Trump so in Minnesota
yesterday there was a really interesting
election so first of all the blue wave
is probably on its way so people who are
who are kind of whistling through the
past the the graveyard here maybe I'm
maybe it's wrong maybe it turns out that
Republicans somehow hold on to the house
maybe it turns out that everything is
fine if the registrations in Minnesota
are and the indicator is that Morrissey
over at hot air points out the data
don't look particularly great for
Republicans Minnesota of course was a
state the president from nearly 1:00 it
was much more competitive than Hillary
Clinton certainly thought that it was
going to be and Minnesota last night it
had a bunch of primaries the way it
works in Minnesota is they it's an open
primary but when you go in you can pick
a ballot and then you have to vote on
that team's ballot so if you are a
Republican you could theoretically
and pick the Democratic ballot but then
you have to vote on the Democratic
ballot the whole way well last night the
Democrats voted on their ballots
two-to-one in ratio over the Republicans
so there are a bunch of primaries on the
Republican side but Democrats basically
showed up at a two-to-one margin over
Republicans just for the primaries that
suggests that Minnesota is going to be
extraordinarily blue this November and
if that's any indicator nationally it
shows that the the level of enthusiasm I
the Democratic side is extremely high
but the real story from last night in
Minnesota is that the Republican
gubernatorial races between former
Minnesota governor Tim Pawlenty who you
remember from his lackluster 2012 run
for president he was in the race for all
of about five seconds before he dropped
out because he is about as colorful and
interesting as dishwater and he was
running again against a guy named Jeff
Johnson whose Commissioner from Hennepin
County and Pawlenty was heavily favored
and then Pawlenty lost and the reason
that Pawlenty lost it is widely
perceived as that Pawlenty was not
supportive enough of President Trump so
going all the way back to 2016 after the
p-word tape came out the tape of
President Trump talking about grabbing
women by their genitals Tim Pawlenty had
said that President Trump was unsound
uninformed unhinged and unfit to be
President of the United States and so
this came up in the campaign here was
the final ad that was cut by by Jeff
Johnson in this particular race and you
can see him slamming Tim Pawlenty Tim
Pawlenty called Donald Trump unhinged
and unfit to be President just weeks
before the election against Hillary
Clinton
Jeff Johnson supported Donald Trump both
before and after the election and it
matters when the Supreme Court in our
economy were on the line Tim Pawlenty
stuck his finger in the wind I'll lead
based on principle not polling and I
won't panic when it matters most I'm
Jeff Johnson the conservative in this
race and I hope to earn your vote vote
Jeff Johnson okay so that was the the
basic that was the basic pitch that was
made is that it was terrible awful
terrible for Pawlenty to say those
terrible terrible things about a man
who'd just been caught on tape saying
who's grabbing women by the genitals and
this was enough to swing the primary
against Pawlenty Pawlenty basically
admitted as much he said listen you know
I'm out of step in the Trump era and I
want to talk about what Pawlenty gets
wrong here and what there
public an party gets wrong and what the
Republican base gets wrong so I think
everybody gets something wrong here here
Tim Pawlenty was explaining why he lost
last night here was his explanation
people are gonna ask you what do you see
in this result I think you know the
circumstances we live in in the era of a
different kind of leadership in terms of
President Trump and the like and I just
don't fit well into that era into that
picture okay so he basically says I will
now recede into the West and he will he
will not be back in the near future now
the reality is that Pawlenty also lost
because he was always milquetoast
Pawlenty lost because he went was a
lobbyist for four years after he was
governor of Minnesota and after he ran
for president in 2012 so it wasn't like
he was a foregone conclusion he was
going to win but his anti-trump stance
really cost him and he's not the only
one obviously mark Sanford the
Republican representative from South
Carolina
he has been ousted now in a primary
Senator Jeff Flake in Arizona was ousted
senator by oh well he basically said he
would retire bob Corker and tennessee
basically said he would retire president
Trump has become a litmus test for a lot
of Republicans and the reason for that
is institutional loyalty but it's a
little bit more than that I think that
some of the institutional loyalty to
president Trump using President Trump as
a litmus test is partially justified I
think it's partially justified and I
think that it is partially unjustified I
think that it is is justified in the
sense that people want to see you fight
for your party and it's unjustified in
the sense that if you could if you
criticize President Trump for a good
reason
maybe it's because he deserves to be
criticized I don't explain a little bit
more about that in just a second but
first let's talk a little bit just just
for a second let's talk about your sleep
quality the reality is you're not
sleeping as well as you could be the
reason you're not sleeping as well as
you could be is because of the sheets
upon which you are sleeping so you don't
think about your sheets you just went
down to your local Sears and you picked
up the cheapest set of sheets you could
find you're like oh who cares it's just
a piece of cloth what does it matter
well the answer is it does matter
because a nice sheet makes your life so
much better people just don't spend
enough money on sheets frankly and if
you don't give a about sheets then
you know you're not going to be able to
actually sleep well at night and that's
where Boleyn branch comes in everything
bull and branch makes from bedding to
blankets it's made from pure 100%
organic cotton which means they start
out super soft they get even softer over
time and can buy directly
them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets can cost
up to a thousand bucks in the store but
Bullen brand sheets are only a couple of
hundred bucks so even if you're looking
at a luxury sheet get this it's a lot
less expensive and it's just the same
quality there are three ex-presidents
who sleep on these sheets they are
fantastic shipping is free you can try
them for 30 nights Bolin bran sheets are
so good that when my wife and I got them
we actually threw out all of our other
sheets and only got Bowlin branch
they're that comfortable if you don't
love them you can send them back for a
refund you're not gonna want to send
them back so get you started right now
my listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at bull and branch comm
promo clip Ben that's bol el and branch
comp remote code Ben again 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets at bulla and
branch comm promo code Ben okay so back
to Pawlenty and this and then Donald
Trump is the new litmus test for the
Republican Party so you cannot be you
just cannot be in the Republican Party a
winning electoral candidate and be
highly critical of the President of the
United States and this is different than
it was during george w bush's tenures
when george w bush was president there
was a feeling that you could cross bush
and get away with it you cannot cross
Trump and get away with it so why is it
the Trump has become such a litmus test
well why I think it's because of
attitude so there's been this attempt to
intellectualize Trump there all these
people Henry Olson over the Manhattan
Institute and a variety of Salinas IDO a
lot of people trying to wrap a sort of
intellectual veneer around what it is
about Trump that is so appealing there's
only one thing about President Trump
that is so appealing and it is an
appealing thing and it's that he punches
people right what is appealing about
President Trump everybody knows the son
gut level is that President Trump is a
fighter right this was the he fights
thing during 2016 and as I said during
2016 he has a hammer in search of a nail
sometimes he hits a nail sometimes he
hits a baby to understand why that's so
appealing to the Republican base you
have to understand that this was a
missing portion of the Republicans soul
for years and years and years and years
okay Trump won the primaries because he
was by far the most aggressive
no-holds-barred candidate there's just
no question about it Republican primary
voters figured that he would do to
Hillary Clinton what he did to Jeb Bush
namely Manhandler and then throw her
through a wall which is what he did to
Jeb Bush and they weren't totally wrong
about that right Trump in the debates I
remember watching the primary debates
and thinking to myself you know it would
be really amusing as he Trump on stage
with Hillary
right didn't everybody think that didn't
everybody think this would make great TV
and he would just hit her with the
kitchen sink that it wouldn't matter
you'd bring up Juanita Broderick in
debate and he'd be the kind of guy who'd
bring up anything and he did you
fulfilled his promise right so he piles
row of Hillary Clinton after pile
driving Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz and
brutalizing Jeb Bush
what's more backing Trump in the
Republican in the Republican primaries
and in the general election lent voters
a sense that they were in the fight you
have to understand I think 2012 actually
broke the country in a lot of ways after
Mitt Romney who's the cleanest candidate
in the history of American politics was
destroyed by Barack Obama and the
Democratic on flexuz Andrew Breitbart
called it after the Democrats turned
that clean candidate into a sexist who
wanted to put women in binders and put
black people back in Chains and forcibly
cut gay kids hair and stick dogs on the
top of cars Republican voters basically
went full Sean Connery in The
Untouchables remember the famous scene
in The Untouchables where Sean Connery
is sitting there he's Malone he's
sitting there next to Eliot Ness played
by Kevin Costner and Sean Connery says
to him what are you prepared to do he
says what are you prepared to do and
then he says if you really want to fight
this thing right they pull a knife you
pull a gun he sends one of yours to the
hospital you said what a fish to the MOG
right you remember that whole spiel
that's how Republicans felt after 2012
they felt like okay now we're in a knife
fight so let's bring a gun Trump is the
knife and the morgue and all of the
consequences for bad Democratic action
wrapped up into one giant orange package
of it right that was the that was what
Trump was and that's what Trump still is
and so the Republican base began asking
its politicians the same question that
Sean Connery asks right what are you
prepared to do right that was that's the
question that everybody is asking Tim
Pawlenty and every Republican primary
candidate and if they're not willing to
defend Trump people take that as a lack
of courage in fact the worst things
Trump says or does the more the primary
base sees that is a mark of courage to
defend him right this is the weird
counterintuitive logic is that if Trump
does something really bad really
polarizing and somebody on the Left
criticizes him the question is you want
Trump to win don't you you want the left
to lose don't you so if you really had
any balls you'd actually just support
what Trump just said right if it turns
out that there is an n-word tape and
people say well I'm not going to go
along with Trump on that there will be a
large portion of the Republican base who
will say how dare you not go along with
Trump on that not because they
the n-word but just because everything
is what are you prepared to do test
everything is a do you have the stones
to stand up with the man who defeated
Hillary Clinton do you have the courage
to stand up but the man who saved
America right no matter what Trump does
it's become now a test not of Trump but
of the people who are willing to support
him because the question is what are you
prepared to do are you prepared to send
people to the morgue are you prepared to
use a gun
now Trump could make all of this easy by
just not doing that stuff right if you
just didn't do that stuff then the
loyalty test would be easy because you
could be loyal to good principle and
also be loyal to President Trump and you
wouldn't have to criticize I mean
everything would be hunky-dory but
that's not what Trump does that's not
what from ties every black mark on his
record becomes a sort of referendum not
on Trump but on all of the other
candidates who are out there and the
problem is there are two sides to this
equation it's not just Republican
primary voters who are voting in
elections folks every time Trump does
something bad and the Republican base
says what are you prepared to do to
defend this guy the Democratic base is
willing to show up in twice the numbers
okay so this is why it's imperative that
from not actually forced the choice it's
why it's imperative that Trump not
actually force the choice but it is
important to recognize that Trump is
filling a gap the Republican Party left
Trump did expose a crack in the
Republican political facade which was in
unwillingness to challenge prevailing
political norms or he'd go out there and
he would say politically incorrect
things some of which were true some of
it was just him being a jackass but some
of that stuff was true and a lot of
people said okay well he's at least
willing to I mean he drove right through
that thing like Oh through political
correctness like a like a truck driving
through a plate-glass window and a lot
of people on the right resonated to that
and then they say okay well what are you
willing to do to maintain the shattering
of that glass because good that that
glass was shattered and if the answer is
that you're not willing to go along with
whatever silly thing from did today well
then that means that you're not loyal
enough that is why Trump has become such
a litmus test now is there an answer for
conservatives who don't actually back
some of the stuff that Trump says or
does yes there is the answer is the same
as it was before Trump was ever on the
scene and that is you actually have to
show that there is some fight in the dog
you actually have to show that you are
willing to step up and battle the left
with just as much alacrity as president
Trump has battled the left you have to
show that you are willing to go in
you're willing to go to political war
with people on the left in favor of
conservative principles
just to go to latin war with the left
but you have to show that you are
willing to step onto the battlefield and
punch somebody in the mouth rhetorically
if they deserve it
you have to show that you're in the
fight the big the reason Trump exists is
because the Republicans didn't feel like
they were in the fight Trump came along
he felt like he was in the fight and now
everything he does is a referendum on
whether you are in the fight or not the
other way to do this is that you have to
independently show that you are in the
fight you can't wait for the president
to leave you can't be conciliatory you
can't go around pretending that the left
isn't a threat to the American Way of
life you actually have to go out and
fight yourself if you're an independent
fighter you can get away with this stuff
but the perception cannot be the
perception cannot be that you are
harsher on President Trump than you are
on the left and that you are willing to
undercut President Trump because you
want strange new respect from folks who
are on the other side of the aisle
that's what happened in Minnesota last
night that's why Trump has become a
litmus test for so much of the
Republican base and that's why the best
move here is for President Trump to stop
making silly mistakes for the base to
recognize that sometimes president Trump
makes silly mistakes and for the base to
be intellectually honest enough to
recognize that when a politician
criticizes President Trump it's not
because that politician wants President
Trump to lose or the conservative agenda
to lose maybe they're criticizing him
because he did something wrong this goes
back to our institutional loyalty point
if you are so loyal to an institution
you are green-lighting bad stuff maybe
you ought to examine your own principles
because institutional loyalty is only
earned when the institution itself is
promulgating good things more than it is
promulgating bad things or when you are
not promulgating bad things in order to
uphold an institution that you think is
promulgating good things right we have
to hold ourselves to a higher standard
as moral human beings okay so in just a
second I want to get to Omarosa and an
institution that certainly does not hold
itself to higher standards this would be
our mainstream media but first we're
gonna have to go over to Daily wire calm
for $9.99 a month you can subscribe to
daily wire you get the rest of the show
live you get the rest of Hannibal Clavin
show live the rest of Michael nolza show
live and get a lot of stuff it's awesome
also you get the leftist here's hot or
cold tumblr it's right here you can't
see it that's because when I go on the
road it becomes invisible but it is just
that fantastic it is great I actually
create a mini cloaking device just
wouldn't be stolen by TSA this this this
leftist here's hierarchal tumblr
delicious I mean just spectacular so go
check that out for $99 here you got that
that's the annual subscriptions cheaper
than the monthly also when you subscribe
a YouTube
I tunes you get access to our somebody
specials and we have a great one coming
up this Sunday Greg Gutfeld is stopping
by and Greg is terrific and here's a
Greg talking about it hey I'm Greg
Gutfeld this week on the bench appear Oh
show Sunday special I'm appearing we're
gonna talk about politics pop culture
obviously Donald Trump my new book we're
going to talk a lot about my new book
because frankly I'm trying to sell the
damn thing but tune in it's gonna be
great okay so go check that out
subscribe to YouTube or iTunes we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you
now even while I am critical of our own
side and the other side for for
green-lighting bad behavior simply in
order to create a litmus test of loyalty
against the other side it is important
to recognize that the left is
threatening America's Way of life
they're a bunch of things left does that
are really threatening to true morality
here's an example Chelsea Clinton who is
considered a moderate within the
Democratic Party
she didn't event the other night at
which she talked about legalizing
abortion and she suggested that
legalizing abortion was good because it
had created economic growth so killing
babies fun for profit it is not a
disconnected fact two dresses t-shirt of
1973 that American women entering the
labor force from 1970 to 2009 added
three and a half trillion dollars to our
economy right like the net new entrants
of women that is not disconnected from
the fact that Roe became the law of the
land in January of 1973 I mean once you
kill babies then women could go to work
I mean doesn't that seem like a nice
moral thing to do you understand why
people on the right are so hands high
left right the reason is because of
stuff like this the moral equation that
says look as soon as we could start
killing children in the womb suddenly
women could work as like associate
lawyers at law firms and put in twenty
two hundred billable hours and we added
a bunch of money to the economy she's
literally putting a price on children
it's so funny folks on the Left will say
that Marco Rubio puts a rice a price on
children because he took money from the
NRA
okay the Democrats literally put prices
on children with comments like that she
literally said that the slaughter of
legitimately a million babies a year in
the United States for the last 30 years
right the last 30 longer than that last
45 years did that kill the mass killing
of children right tens of millions of
children it was worth it because like
for each one of those kids we may have a
probably like a thousand bucks I mean
probably made like we probably made ten
thousand bucks for each one of those
dead kids you wonder why the right is so
solid and it's support of President
Trump it's also because the left refuses
to be reasonable on any of these issues
so as I say as the out-group threat
multiplies the in-group becomes more
cohesive and that's something the left
should recognize here now meanwhile the
media have been doing yeoman's work to
demonstrate exactly where they stand on
all of these issues that they've been
continuously granting all
sorts of credibility to Omarosa
Manigault who continues to make the
rounds even though everyone knows that
she's sort of a pathological liar
that was her reputation when she was on
the apprentice I believe she was fired a
couple of times from the Clinton
administration three times on the
apprentice and now from the White House
so she that lady has been fired more
often than then a Bill Clinton cigar I
mean she's been she has been lit up like
a Christmas tree I mean she's been fired
just a bunch of times anyway
Sarah Huckabee Sanders she makes the
point that the press who are jumping on
all the Omarosa stuff they're doing a
lot to divide the country and she's not
wrong about this frankly if we want to
look at who's creating divisions in the
country I think the media has done more
to divide this country certainly far
more than this president ever has by
elevating people like the author of this
book by focusing on a sparsely attended
rally instead of all of the policies
that this administration and that this
president are in okay and she is correct
about all this it is also important to
note that I morosa is saying stuff that
is completely unverified like she
suggested that Trump's past her I can't
member her name patty white I think that
she was having an affair with Trump in
the book she just sort of suggests that
out of the blue and then she says that
Trump knew all about the WikiLeaks
emails before they were actually
revealed which would in fact implicate
President Trump in the hacking and also
indirect conspiracy with the Russian
government
here's Omarosa saying this again with no
supporting evidence and this was
parented all over the place by the media
yesterday Donald Trump know about those
emails before they came out absolutely
he knew about them yes he knew what was
coming out before WikiLeaks released
them you're saying Donald Trump had a
back-channel
I didn't say that you did but I will say
that how do I expose the corruption that
went on in the campaign and in the White
House I'm gonna continue to blow the
whistle on all okay so she says she
spoke to Muller about all of this if
that's really the case if there was any
evidence of that then we go find out in
the Muller investigation but if you
believe I'm Arosa on this then I think
he got a screw loose I mean she's she's
insanely dishonest but the media are
treating her as though everything she
says is gospel truth and also the media
are going overboard by suggesting that
everything the President Trump does is
equally bad so for example the president
called amorosa a dog he said that she
was basically fired like a dog which as
we discussed yesterday is one of his
favorite turns of phrase he has said
that half the united states been fed
like
Doug right it's just his favorite thing
to say the media declared yesterday that
this was the worst thing anyone had ever
said Joe Scarborough who gave President
Trump millions and millions of free ad
dollars on MSNBC during the presidential
run before turning on him and deciding
the Trump was actually a bad guy he says
that Trump opened the door to genocide
by calling Omarosa
a dog yes I mean yes right on the money
there Joe I'm not an exaggeration and my
goodness during the Holocaust Nazis
referred to Jews as rats in Rwanda
genocide was often justified with the
calling Tutsis cockroaches slave owners
throughout history considered slaves
subhuman animals but you can see time
and time again and I'll go to ally
Schaer this is actually how dictators
and tyrants open the door and they do it
by dehumanizing their political
opponents yes the Holocaust is right
around the corner because Omarosa
Manigault taped President Trump in the
Oval Office and then Trump called her a
dog and said she was be fired like a dog
that's exactly the same as the Nazi
spending years and years labeling all
Jews rats and it's the same thing as the
government in Rwanda labeling the Tutsis
cockroaches exactly the same thing right
on the money media I can't imagine why
people don't trust you on any of this
stuff but this brings up the other big
story of yesterday and that of course is
the controversy over the n-word
okay the controversy over the n-word so
this I'm Rosa manacled suggested that
there was a tape of president from
saying the n-word this had been long
rumored that there was an apprentice
tape in which the president dropped the
n-word now I should say that if the
President did in fact drop the n-word
and and drop it in a in a you know
specifically derogatory fashion
obviously he's not doing like the
Michael Scott Chris Rock routine from
the office where he just is repeating a
comedy routine or he's rapping lyrics or
something if the president says you know
those stupid and words or he if he says
anything like that then I think a
primary is probably into her in the
Republican Party but there's no evidence
that any of this happened right because
if that tape existed do you think that
might have come out by now it was long
rumored during the 2016 campaign that
tape if that tape exists that suckler is
in the public sphere by now
no question about it but there's a
problem inside the White House and that
is you can't say anything without
president Trump's prior approval there's
a problem within the comms team over at
the White House the problem is if you
make a reasonable assumption
it may not be reasonable in light of
what President Trump wants you to say so
if dana perino who's the press secretary
under george w bush had been asked is
there a tape of president bush saying
the n-word dana perino would have just
said no right no there's not and then if
it had come out there was she would have
been shocked and horrified sarah
huckabee Sanders has asked about this
and here's what she said in this of
course was the the statement that
generated a thousand headlines yesterday
guarantee the American people will never
gear Donald Trump I can't guarantee
anything but I can tell you that the
president addressed this question
directly I can tell you that I've never
heard it okay so that is not a great
response from Sarah Huckabee's it hurts
right you'd want her to just say no or
she could theoretically just read from
sweet because from tweeted it out the
problem is that if you're the she has
the worst job in America being being the
press secretary for President Trump is
very difficult because if you say
something that is reasonable like no he
didn't
Trump could call you into his office and
say you know I didn't but I just want to
troll the other side like there could be
a thousand reasons why President Trump
doesn't like what you say so Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is obviously going to
avoid implicating any hard answer here
even though a hard answer would be
better because like really what's the
downside if she says no and then it
turns out that the tape breaks so what
like so what what are they gonna say
that she's a liar they're already saying
she's a liar they're gonna say that the
administration was dishonest like okay
okay well what exactly is the downside
but the fact that the media have jumped
on the n-word stuff without a shred of
evidence that this is actually happen is
pretty astonishing it really is I mean
that again we have not a shred of
evidence that Trump has used the n-word
the man's been public for 30 40 years 50
years probably of his career there's no
evidence that he's ever used the n-word
the people who amorosa is quoting say
that he never used the n-word and then
there was a tape they played on CBS
Omarosa talking to a couple of other
campaign staffers like Katrina Pierson
and Katrina Pierson saying he said it he
said it well just because Katrina
Pearson said Trump said something I mean
that's like if somebody was having
conversation with
they said you know did there's a rumor
out there that president Trump slipped a
donkey down in Mexico one day right I
would probably be like yeah maybe like
who the elbows right like the answer is
he didn't of course but when you're in a
conversation with people you just sort
of say stuff so that is so using that as
evidence that there actually is an
n-word tape is just evidence the media
is willing go out of its way for
anything remember these are the same
folks exactly the same folks who said
that Linda Tripp was the worst person
who ever lived for having taped Monica
Lewinsky talking about an affair in the
Oval Office with Bill Clinton
so taping was bad when it was about Bill
Clinton and we should tear the Linda
Tripp a new one and we shouldn't take
her seriously and she was a liar but
Omarosa Manigault a proven liar over and
over and over a turncoat politically
about 80,000 different ways right we
should definitely believe her when she
says that there's an outstanding n-word
tape for the President of the United
States and as I said yesterday if there
is an n-word tape it's a problem it's a
problem it's a problem in a variety of
son says it obviously the President of
the United States should not be somebody
who utters the n-word the the Republican
Party the party of Abraham Lincoln
should not be the party of the n-word
but there's no evidence from said any of
this so what the hell are we even
talking about the only reason we're
talking about this is because the media
have decided to grant additional
credibility to a woman who has none and
that is a serious problem with the media
and their own credibility and
demonstrates full scale what their
agenda is in in all of this okay time
for some stuff I like and then we'll do
some things I hate and then we will do a
song because we need a little bit of
uplift today so things I like this is
just hilarious
okay so in another example of people
being called racist or not actually
racist they're just dumb there is an
episode of the $100,000 pyramid and in
this episode of the $100,000 pyramid one
of the contestants is given a clue and
he is supposed to convey to the person
sitting across from him what the
category is the category as you'll see
is people whose last names are Obama and
now the Quai that that's a very easy
category to the bottom of the pyramid as
you know from the pyramid game the the
questions get harder as you get up
toward the top so this is an easy one
right all you have to say is Barack
Michelle Malia Sasha all right that's
all you have to say and they don't get
people whose last names are Obama okay
that is not what this guy says and it is
really
funny for $50,000 here's your first
subject bin Laden just just excellent
excellent stuff right there so is you a
blatant evil racist no he's an idiot
okay can we just like make a couple of
distinctions in American life if you mix
up Obama and Osama it's cuz you dumb
it's not because you think that Barack
Obama is actually an Afghani terrorist
or a Saudi terrorists living in the
caves of Afghanistan or buried at the
bottom of the ocean at this point like
that's not that's not actually a thing
but people were like hah this is a
racist contestant because he conflated
Obama and Osama or he's just an idiot I
have a basic rule about politics that
which you cannot attribute to stupidity
you may be able to contribute attribute
it to malign influence and malign intent
otherwise just attribute things to
people being stupid people are dumb
people are so damn stupid like this is
one of the great tragedies of life I've
courted a thousand times I'll quote it
again Adam Carolla says and he's exactly
right one of the great disappointments
in life is when you're 5 years old you
look around at the world you see all
these adults and all these adults have
cars and they have nice clothes and they
have houses and they can buy nice things
and they have money in their wallets and
they all look so put together and you
think god those adults are so smart and
then you become an adult and you realize
that all of the adults around you are
the same kids who are sitting next to
you picking their nose and eating it
when you were 5 they're the same people
ok adults are just as dumb as you as the
kids were around you when you were a kid
and so when you look at people that
maybe just to be nice we should first
attribute things to people being idiots
and also to be accurate because most
people are idiots now I think that that
is true with regard to government
conspiracy theories as much as it is
true with regard to things like the
$100,000 pyramid which brings us to
things that I hate so
okay so when it comes to things that I
hate there's there's a always an intent
to suggest that everything bad that
happens in life was part of a bigger
plan we're sort of like the Joker this
way well you know the Joker in the Dark
Knight he says nobody cares when bad
things happen so long as there's a plan
but the minute there's no plan then
everybody goes crazy okay that's that's
the stick in The Dark Knight and that's
true that's true so we tend as human
beings to attribute plans to people that
don't actually exist it happens all the
time it happens to you in your personal
life like your spouse forget somethings
like why are you ignoring me why didn't
you listen to me as I go I just forgot
all right wasn't paying attention
almost all marital conflict is driven by
people miss attributing motives for
stuff that is basically people being
dumb it's true for virtually all
interpersonal conflict it's pretty rare
that people are really so evil and mean
that they intend to do something really
nasty most people are just doing stupid
things but when it comes to government
conspiracy theories it's very easy to
attribute malignity to people's
intentions so take for example the the
Trump Tower meeting so the left
attributes the Trump Tower meeting to
the Millian intent of President Trump to
collude with the Russians in stealing
the election or it's possible Donald
Trump jr. is sort of dumb and the Donald
Trump jr. when it comes to this when it
comes to meeting with the Russians he's
like oh they've got some Oppo I like
Apple let's go get the Oppo and that was
pretty much the end of it now is that
bad yeah is it like he's sitting with
Vladimir Putin over a chess board bad
not really it's mostly just people being
stupid and maybe a little bit bad
okay the stupid and a little bit bad I
think describes most human behavior well
the same thing is true with the theories
that are being promulgated on the right
about the Trump Tower meeting so there's
a new theory that's been put out by Lee
Smith
I believe Lee Smith writes for the
Weekly Standard is that right well Lee
Smith was on with Tucker Carlson and he
has a theory about the Trump Tower
meeting his theory is that the Trump
Tower meeting between Donald Trump jr.
and Natalia vessel met skaia who is a
Russian connected lawyer it was actually
set up by fusion GPS and Hillary Clinton
that it was this complex scam in which
the Russians would approach Donald Trump
jr. with an offer of Oppo specifically
to entrap Donald Trump jr. and then it
would be released that the Russians were
in bed with the Trump camp
and then all of this would bring the
campaign crashing down about Donald
Trump juniors ears and his father's ears
here's Lee Smith articulating this
theory on the Tucker Carlson I think one
of most important things to to look at
it's actually there's one key to it and
that is the Russian lawyer that is
supposed to be the test of the proof of
collusion this was a client land Simpson
and Glenn Simpson was the person who was
responsible for producing the Clinton
funded dossier so how does this happen
how did this combination happen how are
all these people in the same room yeah
the answer to how all these people in
the same room is because everybody in
political circles in the United States
at a high level knows each other and
also people are dumb so how about that
how about people are just stupid okay
there's a big hole in this particular
listen I know a lot of my listeners love
this theory the Donald Trump jr. didn't
do anything wrong and that it was all
about Hillary Clinton manipulating from
behind the scenes and all the sort of
nonsense here's why the health area
doesn't hold up if Hillary Clinton
manipulated the meeting and then if she
knew about the meeting
why didn't you release information on
the meeting the next week okay why
didn't fusion GPS just say the Russians
are meeting with they met at Trump Tower
with the Trump campaign in order to
collude to get Apple on Hillary why why
did that wait until after the election
in order for that information to be
broken and the answer is because this is
again a tributing conspiracy where no
conspiracy lies I just I don't buy it
now there are certain people who I think
are intelligent enough to actually
participate in bad behavior but anything
that requires a lot of people
coordinating is probably unlikely
individuals doing dumb things is a lot
easier than an entire network of people
coordinating to accomplish a purpose
that's why most businesses fail if it
were that easy most businesses would be
successful okay other things that I hate
so there's a there's an article in the
UK son today about how rough Americans
have it it is titled the average
American takes less holiday time than a
medieval peasant economist reveals so
the u.s. is the only advanced country
with no national vacation policy
whatsoever plus has a culture of working
long hours according to Business Insider
many American workers must keep on
working through public holidays and
vacation days often go unused the advent
of smartphones means that people are not
logging off as often as they were before
they say medieval peasants face disease
famine are being bumped off in bloody
Wars but the church
often enforced mandatory holidays to
prevent the serfs from uprising sundays
were national holidays there were breaks
after harvest season now listen as a
dude who takes off every Friday night to
Saturday night I'm a I'm a fan of
holidays I have enforced holidays via my
religion but if the implication is that
we have it rougher than medieval serfs
I'm gonna go no on that they're all dead
at 37 had no teeth and we're watching
their kids die in infancy so no on that
one of the things that makes modern
civilization pretty amazing is the fact
that we have all of these technologies
which are bolstered by a system of work
that has become more and more
sophisticated plus if you really want to
equate the kind of work that medieval
peasants serfs were doing but the kind
of work that you're doing sitting on
your ass at the office all day punching
numbers into a machine I'm gonna go no
on that as well
a medieval serfs were out there fighting
disease while trying to dig up rock out
of their field not the same thing so
again yes I'm sure that it's just like
medieval serves it's Americans are
living just like needles I keep hearing
how rough Americans happened then I look
around America and there are certain
people who have it rough but overall I
think we're doing pretty well like as in
the best in human history
so can we cut out all of the alarmism
about how rough americans have it as a
general rule as a general okay time for
a solemn so we are on Psalm number five
we've been remissed for the past couple
of weeks and not going through it so um
so let's go through this one this is
this one is for the director of music
for pipes a psalm of David remember all
the Psalms were songs and one of the
beautiful things about the Psalms is
that indeed they were sung and that is
how they're remembered one of the
beautiful things about the the Bible is
that much of the Bible is written in
lyric much of it is written in verse the
song of the Book of Psalms was meant to
be sung they're actual tunes to a lot of
these and oral legacies tend to bring
cultures even further than written
legacies a lot of time written legacies
are not confined to time in space but
oral legacies tie you to your parents
every time you hear it and to your
ancestors every time you hear a song it
reminds you of when your parent was
singing you that song every time you
hear something on the radio you're
immediately shifted back to the first
time you heard that song or the most
important time you heard that song and
that ties you it roots you in a history
that is important for you to remember as
you go forward in life I remember one
time back during there's a Passover
Seder this is probably 15 years ago
maybe longer maybe maybe 17 or 18 years
ago and I used to study violin with one
of the top 10 teachers in the world and
my violin teacher was an expatriate from
the Soviet Union he had been the the
first chair or the concert master and I
believe as the Kiev Philharmonic and
Jewish guy but because he lived in the
Soviet Union you weren't allowed to
practice Judaism in the Soviet Union
they had tried to root it out and so he
had not had a peso verse a Passover
Seder he was in his 80s he not had a
Passover Seder for legitimately 70 years
heimo didn't remember any of the Seder
and then we got to a portion of the
Seder that is sung and suddenly he
remembered his father singing that to
him that is the reason that songs are
actually important it's why so much of
the Bible is written in lyric style in
fact when we read that when we read the
Bible when we read the Torah in in
synagogue there's actually cancellation
no tried to tell sung it's all son it's
not just read we don't actually just
read the words like my bar mitzvah
parsha I still remember the actual
Hebrew of my bar mitzvah Perisher by
memory because I remember the tune that
goes with it right it's it's from parts
rubbish and in the book of
Exodus it's the it's the whole section
where the Jews finally exit Egypt you
remember things that are sung in any
case the psalm says listen to my words
Lord consider my lament hear my cry for
help my king and my god for to you I
pray in the morning Lord you hear my
voice in the morning I lay my request
before you and wait expectantly for
you're not a God who is pleased with
wickedness with you evil people are not
welcome
the arrogant cannot stand in your
presence you hate all who do wrong you
destroy those who tell lies the
bloodthirsty and deceitful and deceitful
you lord detest but I by your great love
can come into your house in reverence I
bow down toward your holy temple he says
that you know when it comes to the
enemies not a word of their mouth can be
trusted their heart is filled with
malice their throat is an open grave
with their tongues they tell lies
there's a lot of focus on untruth and
deliberate untruth is in fact the path
toward ungodliness deliberate untruth
whether you're lying to yourself or
lying to others is the path toward
ungodliness I think that's the lesson of
today's show frankly if you are lying to
yourself or to others about moral values
in order to achieve a certain goal
you're on the wrong side you're on the
wrong side not of history of morality
and we should all keep that in mind as
we go forward because after all what is
politics about but promulgation of
values that are worthwhile and eternal
alrighty we'll be back here tomorrow
with all the latest plus we have our
show tonight over in in Dallas so if you
have not actually purchased a ticket now
is the last chance for you to do so go
over to Ticketmaster live now
it's like a handful of tickets left go
check it out or Phoenix tomorrow night
that it's also a handful of tickets
again Live Nation or Ticketmaster to
check that out and we will see you back
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire Ford
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018